pour le moment on est effectivement sur
trois jours en moyenne de chômage
partiel qui va se transformer en chômage
longue durée puisque l'aéronautique et
durablement touchée est-ce que vous avez
été obligé de licencier est ce que vous
envisagez de licencier alors on n'a pas
été obligée de licencier on avait plutôt
on a arrêté on va dire les contrats qui
devaient s'arrêter cdd intérimaires et
un instant t 20 n'y a pas de on préfère
aller sur déjà ce chômage donc duré
avoir en parallèle de sa toute cette
action
cette action commerciale pour
diversifier trouver d'autres marchés
trouver de voie de développement et pour
le moment il n'est pas il n'y avait pas
de question de parler de de licenciement
en tant que président d'aéro microtech
d'après vous quels sont les atouts de
votre entreprise et des entreprises de
la région pour faire face à la crise
allait alors les atouts de leur taux de
l'entreprise du groupe et dv globalement
on va dire des adhérents du cluster et
puis comme je vais le dire d entreprise
industrielle franche comté mais
bourgogne aussi mais l'industriel est
quand même très fort en franche comté
c'est la même capacité de rebond que les
que les sociétés bull lors de la crise
horlogère et je pense qu'il faut c'est
un moment donné de réinventer son modèle
ou d'avoir plusieurs business model pour
pouvoir aller vers d'autres marchés dont
qui chacun passe réinventer et je crois
que les francs comtois y est les
bourguignons ont cette capacité là pour
vous la clis naumann être une
opportunité
la crise sera une opportunité si on est
capable de résister si on est capable
d'être tous vivants évidemment dans je
pense sur 2021 parce que ceux qui
étaient en mauvaise santé m'a
malheureusement vont sans doute avoir
plus de difficultés peut-être
disparaître ça c'est pour être aussi
conscient de ça et c'est la capacité de
ces entreprises là notamment avoir des
trésoreries notamment faire appel aussi
à la banque publique d'investissement je
veux dire qui est un organe
manque extrêmement dynamique c'est cette
capacité d'être relié en réseau
parce que je crois beaucoup au réseau
pour faire aussi des affaires c'est
cette capacité qui permettra de pouvoir
s'en sortir
vous êtes optimiste pessimiste moitié
des 2 je suis optimiste de tempérament
ça c'est clair et je change pourrait pas
changer c'est un peu ma nature ma
personnalité
par contre ce qui est important c'est
les doors dans le réel et surtout de
s'ouvrir
parce que c'est le moment oui si on se
ferme on peut vraiment avoir des soucis
il faut s'ouvrir s'ouvrir aux autres
écoutez les opportunités sortir de
l'entreprise aussi pour aller chercher à
faire ça c'est le boulot des équipes
commerciales et du chef d'entreprise